en los últimos días lo que estamos
viendo es que el flujo de refugiados
está disminuyendo ayer por ejemplo
fueron 33000 los refugiados ucranianos
que pasaron aquí hasta polonia mientras
que en los días de mayor afluencia hemos
visto que incluso llegaban a ser 140.000
los ucranianos que buscaban un refugio
seguro aquí en polonia esto se debe
principalmente nos lo están contando
estos días tanto los expertos como los
humanitarios a que aquellos ucranianos
que tienen contactos en europa o en
otras ciudades polacas que tienen
familiares viviendo en el exterior o que
tienen un plan para conseguir huir de la
guerra toma la decisión rápida se
marchan de su país en los primeros días
de guerra mientras que las personas que
estamos viendo estos días que salen ya
casi cuatro semanas después de que se
iniciara el conflicto son personas con
menos recursos que no tienen familiares
y que no tienen un plan es decir que
abandonan ucrania sin rumbo fijo es por
eso que las organizaciones no
gubernamentales nos dicen que están
ahora más alerta tienen que prestar
especial atención porque estas personas
son más vulnerables y se quedan
expuestas a las mafias de tráfico de
personas y también de pederastia es lo
que hemos visto estos últimos días aquí
en el pueblo de 3.000 que está más vacío
algunas de las de los centros de acogida
o también en la estación central están
más vacíos de los primeros días pero eso
no es una buena noticia sino que
significa como decimos que los
refugiados que están saliendo ahora
están todavía en más peligro